[Música]
desde hace más de 20 años una comunidad
de mujeres y de hombres se impuso un
desafío fuera de lo común en borgoña
construir un castillo fuerte con
técnicas de la edad nerd un proyecto
faraónico abierto a los visitantes que
propone una inmersión en el corazón del
siglo 37 actualmente a cerca de 40
personas trabajan cotidianamente en esta
obra medieval
decidimos terminar las torres una tras
otra entonces desde hace tres años nos
dedicamos a hacer la torre de la capilla
este año esta torre será cubierta por
una estructura cónica recubierta con
tejas se puede decir que es una obra
maestra
tal como cada mañana el responsable de
la obra les entrega la hoja de ruta a
los artesanos
este es un pequeño dibujo de la puerta
entre dos torres el caballo puede
distinguir un obstáculo como éste yo
creo que sí lo pasaría entre un taller y
otro se fija en todo supervisa hasta el
mínimo detalle es decir que pondremos
nuestros elementos de madera oblicuos
así
la extracción de las piedras es la
primera etapa de la construcción del
castillo un trabajo difícil que requiere
fuerza pero también precisión
he aprendido a cansarme menos
preparo bien los pequeños huecos esto
que estoy haciendo
hay que hacerlos bien para cansarse
menos con el mazo
ahora si está abierto
y para transportar estas piedras a la
obra de ninguna manera se usará una
máquina moderna
todo se hace tal como en el siglo 13
gracias a la potencia de los caballos
los caballos son animales que se prestan
para este tipo de trabajo son manuales
comparado con los bueyes por ejemplo los
bueyes serán buenos para distancias
largas el caballo se usaba más en obras
se le puede pedir que gire sobre sí
mismo que retroceda
esta mañana esta llegó a percherón a
halar a 8 carreras como ésta diariamente
transporta 2 toneladas de materiales
piedras pero también madera cal o
mortero las piedras transportadas al pie
del castillo son lanzadas gracias a esta
grúa de la edad media
permanecemos aquí hasta que haya tensión
sentirás la diferencia ahora atender
esas puedes caminar nunca mires las
tablas porque van a pasar y si lo haces
terminarás en cuatro patas
de acuerdo
este montacargas es la grúa del siglo 13
construido in situ puede alzar hasta 500
kilos con su doble tambor los bloques de
arenisca llegan a sus ubicaciones
definitivas en el muro de la fachada del
castillo fuerte
fíjate juntas
cada año los artesanos reciben el
refuerzo de 400 practicantes que
aprenden sobre oficios medievales
puedes acercarte un poco más es un
trabajo de hormiga y es otra manera de
hacer las cosas de hecho otra forma de
considerar la construcción algo que
durará mucho más tomará 20 años
construirlo pero durará probablemente
unos 1000 años 2000 años las
edificaciones construidas hoy en día con
los métodos contentos años durarán lo
mismo se les preguntó
[Música]
i
ah
en él
en 20 años el camino que ha sido
recorrido es impresionante
1997 en este claro de borgoña no había
nada solo el proyecto lo con un puñado
de apasionados no quería que era de este
tamaño creía que era más pequeño es
impresionante
hacer esto en nuestra época quiere decir
que no hemos inventado nada eran más
inteligentes que nosotros
hoy en día que delon es una empresa
privada financiada únicamente por los
visitantes que vienen a descubrir la
obra cada año 300.000 vienen a explorar
el sitio y a vivir una lección de
historia a cielo abierto a medida que
avanza la construcción nuevos oficios
van apareciendo en el proyecto en
especial el del pintor y una vez más se
usan materiales locales los pigmentos de
color son fabricados a partir de los
ocres de la cantera de las arenas y de
la tierra luego son mezclados con
pegante de piel de conejo un huevo
batido y un poco de agua el
procedimiento ha hecho sus pruebas desde
hace siglos las partes de las pinturas
nasales nos emitidas a fracciones
resisten en vientres que son las más
antiguas en francia con esta receta
datan del siglo 13 entonces funciona
este proyecto es un extraordinario
conservatorio de oficios antiguos
pintar como hace 800 años fundir el
metal con horno de combustión interna
forjar coser piedra caliza para obtener
cal mezclar con mortero sin cemento
delon se reconstruye día tras día la
edad
[Música]